John tell you were the cast of friends
all of our friends in us I'm Rachel yeah
I feel like a shift between being like
one of the guys all the time yeah I mean
at any given moment it just depends on
which room you're in but I think that's
true of everybody periods in my life
like there was a time where I go is
totally Chandler Ryan tried days I was
totally like Joey yeah and we're like
HBO I feel like I'm more like a Ross now
you've been like a real-life Chandler
more so in the past few years about like
growing up you're the Ross you're like
the dweeby dude people used to say I'm
like Chandler all the time when I was
younger
I'm probably only Joey to like a select
group of people speaking of friends
speaking of friends the walking dead
friends mashup I really hope this
doesn't I hope it was a beat actually
what I think it is where it's just the
opening credits the friends
oh boy
[Music]
Oh God spoilers for John Hamner
[Music]
well done Woodcreek factory
woodcreek faction well what those are
great clips to choose yeah well done I
feel like I want this video to get more
popular because I want more of these I
always enjoy the opening of friend is is
so delightful they've always inter
cutted it with the fountain scene that
they air with of the pilot I've seen
friends like a billion times were you
watching friends right now actually
that's like my go-to show to just chill
out and relax I love my favorite show of
all time would you say like once every
year year and a half you do a friend's
revisit oh yeah I'd say that it's been
like that my whole life yeah an entire
life I love that yeah and as I grow
older I get the show even more and the
more experiences I have I get the show
even more I enjoy how much you enjoy
friends you've shown to me I've never
never actually watched it until you
showed it to me and I always more than
that huh yeah I really enjoy it yeah I
think you like reflects life really well
that's I mean I as I get older because
growing up I just kind of view them all
as like being in their 30s their entire
life in the show but then we watch them
like oh yeah they're like season 4
they're still they're just late 20s yeah
it's like you watch them go through a
bunch of situations as you get into
during this time of your life and you
just watch what six people who are
really honest and upfront about their
feelings would do together situation I
feel like I learned a lot of the value
of friendship from friends it doesn't
give you what I was watching it when I
was six
really oh wow they are they really were
your friends growing up yeah for reals
dad hated it thought was way too you
perverted I was one of Catholic school
haha well that's the thing is it's
interesting to know how this show has
aged because it is a little dated in
some ways because things have noticeably
changed culturally since then it's an
interesting time capsule I would love to
do just an entire video talking about
friends I mean why what's stopping us
see
yeah do whatever we're already doing it
the future is now great now we could do
we could spin off a video into that
called Joey the insert of friends of
bringing this full circle oh yeah the
fountain the fountain seen the intro to
friends is great every season they
change up the clips they enter cutaway
when they're listening the cast members
because it's the one thing this is
missing is there's no kind of famine
scene from The Walking Dead in any way
or it's just the same like the same
segments they can just keep cutting back
to I guess over trying that would like
Jeffrey Dean Morgan at the beginning or
something no not really
there's got to be a walk into you know
it shouldn't be a found it should be
that big Walker Pitt thing that season
six is all about that yeah they'd
surround that pit for a while well what
I'm saying is the show you see them
start off as these dudes who are single
in their 20s and they just have adult
problems you know they have a few wacky
hides yes like the beef stories always
whacked it tends to be wacky but then
there's usually like Oh something going
on with the character that's like rather
serious and it's usually involved in a
relationship or a career I always feel
like the main story is a cartoon and the
B story is a comic strip cartoon well
yeah because like it is there are ways
in which it is sort of like to me it's
like a live-action serious there like a
man but cartoons like doing Ross and
Rachel when they were dating in the
beginning and then they and then he
slept with another woman like they kept
it funny but a lot of that got really
serious interior it's it's it's dramedy
in that in that regard I friendly
started to get it I was I was like you
know after so many years like you are
witnessing some sort of little community
relationship that has endured you do get
to care about it more over time and
through that you can start adding more
serious to your show because people care
about these gathers yeah sure if we
gotta watch them deal with some [ __ ]
we'll be there like the effort were
there have you seen the episode when
Chandler proposed to Monica that I show
you that one I think so yeah dude I cry
every time everything is the first time
an air on TV yet it's like the
commercials like totally revealed
channel proposed the Monica but they
just never showed her say yes yeah yeah
watching that
I in the living room and every single
time it touches my heart yeah yeah and
they play it with such like realism like
they're really engaged yeah that's what
I mean I don't mean cartoon like solids
silly but I mean like it is heightened
you know like there are some yes yeah so
like in that way to me it is like a
live-action cartoon but everyone is very
invested it's like a cartoon about
people yeah because they they're all
good at selling their lines so it feels
very natural but it's all heightened and
that's kind of the magic too is it's a
natural kind of unfolding show that has
a lot of wacky humor by the end of the
show though they all grow in together
you know in case you haven't seen
friends I'm not gonna ruin it but they
all grow they never change we wanted the
same thing for eight years the main
things that they struggle with our
relationship and career a very common
couple struggles for people and life in
America but by the end of that they all
have that taken care of you know each
one of those care set for June but each
one of them have that taken care of
yeah it's bringing this finally full
circle the Rick and the intro constantly
cuts back to the fountain but they
always change it with the seasons of
where they're out of their life now and
then why the tenth season it's kind of
crazy when you're like you see that
footage yeah the first thing they shot
when they all cast these [ __ ]
we gotta have an opening let's all have
you jump in the fan turn em [ __ ]
everybody every episode starts with
here's where it all began and here's
what we exactly know yeah that's cool
there's a lot of little creative juice
to squeeze out of that orange wasn't
expecting this video to become a
full-blown friends conversation hey I
know how much you love friends but you
know what else that I know you're at
least invested in that invested in is
the Walking Dead Oh Joan once you get
that shirt why don't I get hold on Greg
keep them company
alright I'm probably gonna throw in a
jump cut so speaking of Walking Dead and
Friends
Love Actually yeah Walking Dead John
wants to tell where you got that sure I
mentioned
my review of the season seven Franco
teased Franco teach I'm the fool sure
Manny Cote is man look at this look at
this the rake with a machete rig barrel
Gerald's cross bro yeah so Sunday Funday
after their website or whatever
Franco T's dot-com we should know I'll
find the Texan thrower to the Attic fun
no seriously thank you know those guys
they sent us over strands are pretty
bitchin a rock that shirt when I did my
review just cool shirt if you're gonna
send us more shirts I like gonna be in
black honestly like and when we first
got the shirts we both thought they were
bitching Franco oh yeah thought they
were bitching seriously we did we were
like these are some pretty sick designs
the only thing that I came across her
mind that could be on con list for us
not really struck some criticism you
didn't ask for a new shadow was I would
probably wear this shirt oh yeah and
John would probably wear this shirt I
that fits me there are two different
sizes for obvious reasons and John is
way fatter than I am I mean look at him
so definitely an axe out how to start
working out let him have this shirt but
I got an email from you today
Franco tea tea no evil
yes it is this is ruin anything for you
John no I don't well you know nothing
that I didn't know happens already well
there was a death that they show but I
don't think he caught it
oh is it the one this is the big one cuz
I caught that no not the coming women
everyone knows okay then no way gets his
brains bashed in and yeah the other guy
is significantly more brutal than
whatever you saw there yeah friends yes
right the network out away well they
sure just I can't think of any depth and
I saw in this video that I haven't seen
yet so he's oh my god season six
what a [ __ ] oh well people have already
died in season six I'm not sure and he's
also but I know which deaths occur in
season seven okay well I'm talking
I think becoming that guy I didn't catch
it I saw a couple deaths I saw again
Carl I know about that Neen just kills
two people and he's never
very very good sound farm another human
being assertive but hey keeps his mitts
to himself and that's what's important
all right well back to the Wood Creek
faction thinking if we're sparking such
a wonderful discussion I don't think
I've ever taken the time to share on
this channel why I love the show friends
so much I just think it's I think it's
all written beautifully the cast is just
perfect he's the perfect sitcom it
really Bad's my favorite drama my
friends my favorite comedy for sure it's
a good little television Pantheon you
know
never lets me down header there like if
you were the real same two mature adults
separate Joey except for Joe but even
Joey gets a little oh he does grow
actually yeah he learns a lot more what
it means to be like a human Joe into you
we before the special task goodbye
no wait subscribe to the real rejects
Jon's reason said Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram he's a social media manager of
bloom house in the real rejects Blum
house keep saying it wrong
so I everyone's typing it in wrong and
no one knows it because I'm Greg Alva on
the Instagram and Twitter and no one
requested this I just saw the title and
I said I'm gonna watch